- If I wake up and everybody
in my family is alive,
I'm so fucking fired
up, I don't watch shit,
I don't listen to shit, I'm so grateful.
Gratitude, it's just gratitude,
like one life, one at bat, one time.
I'm fascinated by people thinking
that gratitude is the
same word as complacent.
I think people mix words a lot.
(upbeat music)
The biggest fear I have
is for the people that are
actually having success,
because complacency kicks in
and you just get into pattern recognition.
When it's about getting a watch,
or buying a new home,
or getting a new pair of
Yeezy's, you're finished.
And so I see a lot of people
looking for quick highs.
I want to get that girl,
I want to get that guy,
I want to get that plane,
I want to get that car, that
is just not sustainable.
Everybody is looking for
so much outside validation
that they're impatient,
they want to show everybody
they're successful,
thus they're rushing into things.
You have 23 year olds who think
that they don't have
their life figured out
yet they're living for another 80 years.
What progression?
Title, an extra zero in your bank account,
buying dumb shit.
Happiness is the fucking progression.
Most people hear the word patience
and have it confused with
complacency, laziness,
lack of ambition.
It's not true, I actually think patience
has been foundational in my success.
I decided to build my
dad's business for him
for the first 12 years of my career,
that required huge patience
from somebody who thought they were great.
I didn't even start quote
unquote until I was 34.
Patience is huge, it's huge,
and people don't wanna do it
because they want instant gratification,
and more importantly,
instant outside validation.
I mean I am so competitive and hungry
it's probably inappropriate.
At the same token, I genuinely am content.
Being content and
grateful for what you have
and not envious for what you don't have
while still being ambitious
is a different way to think
about being satisfied.
You know there's a reason why
there's a word called gratitude,
and there's a reason why there's
a word called complacency.
And I use gratitude and patience a lot
and I think people think
it's an excuse for laziness
or not going to get it,
and I laugh at that because
there's a whole nother world
that thinks that I'm saying go too hard
and all this does on both
sides of the conversation
is excuses people for
finding in my message
what they're looking
for which is cynicism.
Their cynical point of view.
I'm talking about being
grateful and patient
while having tremendous work ethic
and tenacity and ambition.
Gratitude is my fuel, I'm
grateful, like I'm alive.
Yeah I keep things very basic,
as long as my family's healthy,
it's hard for me to get down.
So I'm just grateful, you know.
When you're like I can
not believe I'm alive,
thank you so much,
and oh my god I can't wait to wake up
and fight and grind and try to win,
I love the game.
You're unstoppable.